We are back, and having the exact conversation
that I fantasized about.
Something that is very honest, very deep, very candid,
humor, breaking it all down.
Thank you for doing this with me.
Okay, there's a quote that I love.
It said, "Trust patterns; not apologies."
Wow.
I know.
Brilliant. True.
Right?
Yeah.
Trust patterns, not apologies.
Do you think he'll ever change?
That's a big part of this process.
This disclosure process that couples go through.
And, you know, some people get to the end of the process
and it's where you have to share the full truth
and process it together.
And some couples choose to stay together.
It did not end up being the right decision for us.
And in the end, what is the most important thing
to both of us, our child.
I mean, it is all about him.
You know, when Anthony, you know, Anthony was sentenced
to federal prison for a little under two years
and my son was five.
And I said, I am not under any circumstances
gonna take him to visit his father.
Like I would not put him...
It will be too traumatic.
And I remember we went away for the holidays
and we traveled.
We were lucky enough to travel with the Clintons.
And here we are, we're at this beautiful house,
this beautiful resort, and we're going out
to dinner every night
and the kids are playing in the beach and playing.
You know, I mean,
it is essentially heaven.
Fantasy.
Right? Fantasy.
And one night we're at dinner with this family
we had just met on the beach,
and the little boy who was my son's age
goes up to his father and puts his hands up in the air
to be lifted.
And the man, the father lifts up the son, Joseph,
and is holding him.
And Jordan turns to me and just breaks down and says,
I want my daddy, I want my daddy.
And was inconsolable.
And that was my, like, that was my moment of
you can give everything to your child
if you have the capacity to
that is tangible, that is things,
but nothing is gonna replace the hole in the heart
that is the absence of a parent.
And I made a promise to him.
The next day I said, I would take him to see his dad.
And I did.
I appreciate that high road behavior so much.
So here you are.
I sure am.
In the analogy and metaphors of books,
what is your next chapter?
Every day I wake up and I'm healthy and happy
and have my little boy.
I am grateful, I have gratitude for that
because I've also had an extraordinarily privileged life.
I've been walked in spaces and places,
you know, that I would have never imagined.
And so I do have the ability to get up and say,
you know what?
I'm opening up my life, my truth,
and it's been pretty amazing.
And I wanna hear that from people
who have walked through the fire.
Okay, last question, woman to woman.
Did you ever tell Anthony,
I love you, but I'm not taking your last name.
(Huma laughs)
It wasn't...
It never even came up.
It was not even an issue
that I was gonna take his last name.
In fact, at one point, yeah, he didn't even ask.
It's so funny.
Okay, you're here this moment.
I can't wait to see what unveils next.
I thank you.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much for this profound conversation
that I've been waiting to have for so many weeks.
Since this book came out, everybody's talking about it.
Huma Abedin, her New York Times best selling memoir,
"Both/And: A Life in Many Worlds" is on sale right now.
Thank you, Huma.
Thank you.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)